gente bom dia 1º obrigado por terem
vindo aqui tem muito onde está aqui na
frente de vocês é essa que é uma platéia
super super seleta vocês sabem que vocês
não estão aqui por acaso muitas pessoas
queriam estar aqui vocês vão escolher
então primeiro lugar reconhecer o com a
com a bola está aqui junto a gente vê
que a platéia é realmente diferenciada
quando a gente vai na mesa de quitutes
as pessoas formam uma fila para comer
então isso já mostra um pouquinho o tipo
de gente que tem aqui geralmente um
ataque de ienes mas desta vez me
sentindo a suécia né
as pessoas às vezes há um público
diferente estou muito feliz de estar
aqui na frente e mesmo assim vocês sabem
o que estão falando só conhece os
assuntos é conectar no são paulo está
bom
beleza né eu sou gabriel ser
empreendedor é eu tenho de falar um
pouquinho do vale do silício é um
assunto que está muito em alta hoje em
dia equipes e perguntou o que tem não
vale o que tem de mágico por que tantas
empresas bacanas sai de lá tantas idéias
saem de lá o que explicar um pouquinho
da minha visão passei cinco anos lá e
falar pra vocês o porque que eu acho que
isso acontece o primeiro que conta um
pouco da minha história pra vocês então
várias várias empresas ainda se vai ser
isso né
google facebook e orkut o twitter se
mudando para lá ea huck que tem na água
da califórnia para que isso aconteça com
byers que é um dos maiores investidores
hoje os carros na minha opinião mais
entende de capital de risco no mundo e
que foi um dos principais mentores do
facebook mas foi uma coisa que eu nunca
esqueci ele falou assim olha que 80% dos
investidores tem escritórios em série de
roupas em uma rua perto lá stefan cara
80% os investidores estão aqui têm
alguma coisa especial a quem quer se
iniciar com o sistema o que será que tem
de diferente
qual é o segredo do vale do silício e
falar um pouquinho pra vocês eu sou
gabriel empreendedor é eu nunca soube
até tenho 25 anos agora né mas até
recentemente eu não sabia que eu poderia
ser empreendedor
eu achava que no brasil só viam na
verdade três tipos de profissão médico
engenheiro e advogado foi cara nessas
coisas que acontecem então eu não sabia
que eu tinha a possibilidade de criar
projetos de fazer coisas novas
né e foi no vai ser isso que eu descobri
isso e foi por muita sorte
na verdade me inscrevi para o vestibular
de medicina no segundo ano do ensino
médio é na época eu tinha um recurso de
adiantamento de série medicina porque a
minha mãe queria que fosse médico então
tá bom vou fazer vestibular pai mãe vai
ter que ser convencida gabriel está bom
vamos fazer vestibular para medicina na
medicina
passei e na época tinha uma lei que se
você passasse na prova você poderia
exigir que as provas do 3º ano fossem
adiantadas e se você terminar se você
tava tava feito com a escola terminou o
ensino médio
fiz isso passei adiante as provas
terminei meus coletes um status assim
totalmente é ideal para quem está no
ensino médio que é eu tinha o status de
aluno observador no terceiro ano do
ensino médio
isso quer dizer que eu ia pra aula
quando eu quizesse né
então imagina essas situações não sabia
o que fazer comigo porque eu sempre foi
muito estudioso muito competitivo mas eu
não era um cara nunca foi um começo
muito quieta né
então meu terceiro ano foi assim foi
como um observador máscara no que ia ser
médio que eu sabia que não queria ser
médica fibular do pé direito também
passei mas a advogada não sei se também
é isso que quero fazer
fiz algumas aulas de medicina demorei
cerca de 17 minutos para descobrir que
não há no ar
não era aquilo que eu queria fazer é
esse foi meu padrinho que me contou a
gabriel lá nos estados unidos é você
pode fazer vários cursos e depois
decidir qual que a faculdade que você
vai se formar esse cara quer dizer que
vou poder fazer uma aula de design de
engenharia de sei lá e filosofia e
depois decidir eu quero estudar falou
sim
onde é que eu escrevo como é que eu faço
a participar estrosi comprar uma revista
da espn news que tinha um top 20
faculdades dos estados unidos
literalmente fiz o recurso para a página
inteira na época fazia sentido pra mim
foi presa em casa tem uma chance só vou
mandar pra todo mundo aqui eu lembro que
eu virei o o ano-novo mandando o
documento mas no documento eu lembro de
ver os fogos de artifício fla fora e as
pessoas já nos coquetéis no jantar
terminando aquela documentação pensando
meu deus do céu que eu fui me meter essa
lembrança depois é voltar pra mim como
alguma coisa assim de puxa valeu a pena
é trabalhar realmente vale a pena depois
do retorno vem se você realmente não
desistir das 20 17 disseram que sim e é
mais alta naquela lista stf
e assim vai acabar stepanek foi a minha
alma mater o lugar onde eu aprendi muito
muito do que eu sou hoje
é quando cheguei estava eu só sabe uma
coisa que eu quero eu quero entender
pessoas para entender gente que eu faço
isso comecei a pensar que a economia é
uma boa graduação para atender pessoas
porque o estudo de mercados ao estudo de
incentivos então isso vai me dar uma ubs
ground para entender seres humanos
comecei um pouquinho mais um pouquinho
da economia percebi que isso não é
suficiente
as pessoas são assim lógico c modelos
previsões de mercado são muito
importantes pela estatística é muito
importante mas as pessoas são emocionais
também as pessoas são movidas a emoção a
intuição heurística qualquer outra
economia e preciso de psicologia então
eu preciso de duas coisas juntas para
ter uma base que mais tarde e ficar mais
popularizada como economia
comportamental hoje em dia a economia
comportamental já uma 11 campo de estudo
até relativamente bem conhecido e
comecei estava como economista
comportamental
estudou teologia e economia
quando cheguei lá eu não sabia falar
inglês direito não sabia como funcionava
o sistema norte-americano não tinha
bolsa de estudos é eu tinha perdido meu
inglês metade jogando metal gear solid e
outra metade fazendo os meus cursos no
brasil é de muita sorte teve ajuda da
fundação estudar jorge paulo lemann
marcel telles a turma que financiou um
pedaço da bolsa de estudos da fundação
recebeu um pedaço da bolsa de estudos da
própria cef
então conseguir trilhar o caminho lá
fora o trabalho mais importante que eu
tive lá é uma das coisas que eu tive que
fazer assim o bravo te ajudar com a
bolsa de estudos com até a escola chip
mas vai ter que trabalhar também não vai
ser fácil não tem que achar um trabalho
na faculdade
esse trabalho foi de comida que nerd que
eu comia de nerd é um cara que
administra o dormitório
exatamente o meu trabalho basicamente a
organizar redes sociais e cuidar da casa
organizava a festa e cuidava da casa ou
seja o quebrava casa e consertava casa
continuamente esse era meu ciclo
eu aprendi muito nesse trabalho porque
foi daí que surgiu mais tarde a empresa
que fundei que ingresse a graça a
plataforma de tecnologia para eventos eo
principal fonte de renda vendendo
ingresso para evento então você procura
festas baladas peças de teatro shows etc
comprou ingresso através do nosso site
recebe um ingresso no seu celular
essa é a grécia a grécia mais tarde a
levantar 10 milhões de reais de
investimento eu tive investimento da
qualcomm do grupo rbs é de brics o grupo
da gef capital de alguns anos que estão
relacionados a steph né
a grécia faz isso a gente atua no
mercado que está crescendo muito em
termos de evento tem muita gente no
brasil sabe que no brasil falta tudo
faltar luz água falta gás mas não faltou
à festa né então ingressos ela atua em
um segmento que é crescente o mercado
grande e que tem pouca tecnologia então
nossa nossa oportunidade ela justamente
atua nesse sentido né
é um mercado difícil encontrar bons
eventos você não tem a plataforma
centralizada em um mercado onde é
difícil comprar ingressos online
são paulo uma grande recessão que tem
uma grande deslocamento de ingressos
pela internet mas a grande maioria do
brasil
mais de 80% dos brasileiros estão
comprando ingresso ainda na lojinha no
que eu acho que eu seja estão comprando
ingressos ou offline ou seja um mercado
muito muito arcaico muito antigo que a
gente está renovando e que uma
plataforma nova para administrar esse
mercado é uma solução que basicamente
organiza eventos que coloca a tecnologia
na mão do produtor e mostra o evento
certo a pessoa certa né
essa ingresso passa a ser rápido porque
eu não quero me focar muito na grécia
hoje eu quero ficar um pouco mais na
interação com o vale do silício que é de
onde veio toda essa é todo esse gasto
essa inspiração para montar o que depois
seria ingresse na eu descobri que eu
queria ser um empreendedor descobriu que
a empreender 40 em contato com vale né
aqui que é o vale vai ser isso tem muito
de steffi é muito tem a ver com o
nascimento desse lugar chamado estava
aqui na minha opinião é paraíso na terra
eu sou suspeito pra falar
mas eu acho que é um dos lugares mais
incríveis do mundo na minha opinião
maior concentração de inspiração por
metro quadrado né
stefan nasce na verdade de uma morte do
falecimento dos fundadores era o filho
do stef clement que morreu de febre
tifóide uma viagem à turquia né
com a morte do filho os bilionários que
eram a família está feliz que já tinham
quer empreendedora de estrondoso sucesso
decidi pegar o dinheiro e aplicar uma
coisa que depois era chamar é de a
fazenda é basicamente a família se junta
e decide um certo dia que cara é
perdemos nosso único filho né quer o
livro está fechadinho
então a partir de agora é só uma frase
da jtf da esposa do do staff de agora em
diante ao do tiro não ficar fora o bell
tios e todas as crianças da califórnia
vão ser os nossos filhos por muito tempo
até foi não teve mensalidade ou seja
criar a faculdade inteira que entrava
estava com todos os custos cobertos
então realmente adotarão aquelas
crianças criar um sistema de educação o
sistema de um ambiente de inspiração
totalmente bancado pela família então
ele já nasce de grandes empreendedores
que querem criar alguma coisa de valor
que começa por aí você entender um pouco
do vale né
depois vieram outros grandes é o grupo
outras grandes pessoas foram muito
influentes na como turma que presidiu
assim a vamos fazer um lugar que eu vale
do silício que o agouti onde a gente vai
da insenção fiscal para empresas e vamos
fazer uma coisa nova
vamos não só investir em projetos
militares naquela época coisa investir
em projetos militares né não havia tanto
aquela ideia de cá e civis né civis
criassem produtos de grande inovação de
grande potencial e também podem investir
nesses produtos né então foi criado um
sistema que era um parque industrial na
época que que tá que a origem desse
parque remete muito empresas como intel
e ibm
as origens da época né à steve jobs
robertinho tudo aquilo e assim algum
alguns dos produtos disso são algumas
más práticas meio assim fora do normal
né 50 prêmios nobéis nos últimos é 50 de
vantagem dos 50 anos
o maior número de tróia wars que é o
prêmio nobel da computação
é 30 bilionários vivos quando estava na
faculdade tinham 12 e não dez estudantes
e dando aula na faculdade é uma piada
ridícula mente arrogante lá que quero
falar se o professor está a deixar o
hotel caírem junta e ganha outro é mais
fácil pra ele mas enfim nem o que aquele
orgulho de casa e conseguiu criar um um
ecossistema de muita muita muita
excelência né e que são essas coisas que
além de ter esse pólo de educação que é
muito importante como todos podem e
ducação muito importante
eu também acho que tem alguns pontos que
permitem a inovação crescer que acho que
pode ser bacana dá até pra gente ficar
aqui a gente consegue aplicar esse no
brasil se a gente consegue é aprender eu
puxar alguma coisa pra gente e deixar
uma coisa clara é eu estou dizendo que
ele tem que imitar os estados unidos não
estou dizendo que a gente tem que é se
espelhar em stephen no vale do silício e
fazer exatamente o que estão fazendo
isto daria errado completamente errado
o que estou dizendo é que tem alguns
pontos que eu acho que podem ser
analisados e que tem valor pra gente
assim como teria em outros muitos países
né
a minha experiência particular do vale
que é um dos cases de sucesso de hoje em
dia né
uma das coisas que eu percebo muito que
tem uma diferença brutal de ter vivido
ali e ter vivido aqui operação eficiente
empreendedores se beneficiam muito de
operações eficientes e eu quero dizer
com isso infraestrutura confiável que
pode escalar hoje quando você empreende
você tem que lidar com falhas em
qualquer ponto da cadeia
você não sabe nem se há ligação vai
completar né
judith judith você não sabe se vai dar
certo isso causa uma incerteza enorme do
ponto de vista operacional porque você
não sabe onde está a falha você não sabe
se o negócio não deu certo porque o teu
parceiro não executou a ordem ou se a
ordem chegou lá porque a ligação não
completou por que a mensagem de voz
chegou porque o porque a mensagem
dizendo que você ligou pra pessoa só
chegou seis horas depois da ligação
operação eficiente então pensar
empreendimentos em coisas que podem
tornar a operação mais eficientes
certamente vão trazer muito valor para a
gente
sessões que permitem escalabilidade
sugestões de de força né
todo o país
tem um sucesso empreendedorismo se apoia
instituições fortes
é muito difícil crescer com o
empreendedor se você não tem segurança
nas instituições é um caso extremo de
insegurança é alguns países na áfrica
por exemplo que do dia para a noite o
coronel ditador não sei o que pode
decidir confisca a sua fábrica
e aí o que você passou 35 anos
construindo é ver o cara lá e confiscou
que tipo de segurança você tem
empreender e que tipo de segurança o
investidor teria que colocar dinheiro
ali não existe uma instituição forte
para te proteger as instituições deviam
ser tracks de eu ser ferramentas para a
gente conseguir operar mais rápido pode
conseguir operar de maneira mais
eficiente com maior velocidade como a
eficácia e não gerar incerteza cara não
sei se tal instituição vai aprovar o meu
amigo competição identificado hawara
terceira junta comercial da 4ª vara
então isso não deveria ser o caso sem
senão a gente puder contar com
instituições fortes vai conseguir também
gerar mais valor e operar mais rápido
ensino experimental eu adoro falar isso
porque eu acho que às vezes nosso ensino
um pouco acadêmico demais é um pouco é é
está um pouco acima da da esfera de de
praticidade e muitas grandes idéias
muitas grandes sacadas vem de ensino
experimental de projetos
vamos fazer um projeto com a empresa x
vamos fazer um projeto com a época vamos
fazer um projeto com o google né
quando kevin que o instagram está na
primeira chamada do boca negócio
totalmente errado que era um fosco é com
fotos e a idéia de colocar de fazer isso
é a grande verdade surgiu na verdade um
programa na influência que era um
intercâmbio que está frio tem influência
onde está a fazer uma aula de fotografia
o professor deu pra ele uma câmera laico
antiga com filtro estourado e com isso
tirar foto aquela laica que entrava
longe demais e começou a ver essas fotos
blindadas totalmente saturadas e açúcar
essa falta muito bonita é levou pro
maquiné que é o nosso brasileiro lá é e
e o mar começou a pensar no filtro da
foto fito da foca isso é bacana goste na
foto com filmes eu posso ser um artista
aplicando esses filtros o sucesso do
instagram todo mundo sabe é o filtro né
o filtro que levou estar à frente dessa
dessa laia estourada surgiu um filho
chamado ex pro os primeiros usuários
agravam reconhecer que alex proya um dos
principais filtros então essa é esse
cruzamento de matérias ensino
experimental eu acho que é fundamental
para fazer o vale do silício que ele é
foco na execução não seja projetos que
viram realidade projetos que são
aplicáveis no mundo real e que a gente
possa também sonhar alto
inventar coisas e pensar redes sociais
maluco sem motivo de nenhuma ideia de
monetização cara como eu vou ganhar
dinheiro sei lá cara mas essa idéia mas
depois eu consigo trazer um plano
concreto e executar a vez que tiver o
contrário é a gente viaja muito e depois
não se arrisca em fazer a coisa virar
realidade
o caso do meu amigo rico
isso é muito importante e quem sabe do
cara do facebook pintou a parede do
facebook teve um grafiteiro que pintou a
parede do facebook os fundadores dar um
pouquinho de ações do cara
o facebook depois valia 100 bilhões por
algum tempo aquela pintura na parede
valia mais do que picasso
então é o caso do meu amigo que ficou
rico com ações é muito importante porque
impulsiona outros cases de sucesso
o último que eu quero falar é esse é pra
menos mais importante essa separação de
criação e critica a gente é muito
crítico a gente é muito a gente censura
de mais 40 têm novas ideias e e já o meu
exemplo final é um é o que está trazendo
um experimento que eu gosto muito de um
neurocientista chamado charles lembra
ele fez o seguinte e colocou o artista
hip hop que compõe letras num f mahé uma
em português não é uma tomografia e
começou a medir a atividade cerebral
desses caras
ele fez duas situações a situação de o
cara falava uma leitura decorada e uma
situação de ocara improvisado um rap
ele lutou duas coisas quando o cara
criava área temporal da ativa não é
surpresa auditiva criação nós estamos
ativos mas quando o cara estava
improvisando o córtex frontal estava
inibido
ou seja esse artista estava inibindo a
própria função de se julgar porque
estava criando então ele precisa exibir
esse sensor essa crítica é essa trava
que a gente tem e assim a nossa nosso
desafio é conseguir operar um sistema um
pouco menos eficiente um pouco mais
burocrático e conseguiu inibir essas
travas para criar soluções do brasil é
cheio de oportunidades se a gente
conseguir realizar algumas algumas
lições algumas algumas algumas práticas
que vai conseguir criar um enorme valor
aqui dentro e criar projetos belíssimos
que não se case para o mundo inteiro e
não só para o brasil
gente obrigado